[Musique]
non
ce pays je laime j'y ai passé toute mon
adolescence
[Musique]
je le sens si fragile il sort de l'enfer
il est à peine au purgatoire dans un
coin de ce quartier de yopougon à
abidjan
toutes les maisons habitées par les
partisans de ouattara le nouveau
président ont été rasés par les
miliciens de laurent gbagbo le président
déchu il y a huit mois de cela
[Musique]
pourtant ici ce matin on chante on danse
la fanfare claironne on veut croire que
les temps ont changé köhler maintenant
est à la réconciliation
c
lambert elles sont bien trop nissan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chef de village victimes de guerre
responsables d'associations tous ont
répondu présents à cette cérémonie pour
la paix et le retour de la fraternité
ce type de rassemblement est fréquent
dans tout le pays depuis quelques mois
[Musique]
il
un homme incarne cette nouvelle côte
d'ivoire qui veut tourner la page après
dix ans de crise et de traumatismes son
nom charles konan banny un ancien
ministre de laurent gbagbo au temps où
il faisait semblant de jouer l'union
nationale le président ouattara a nommé
banny à la tête de la commission
dialogue vérité et réconciliation
comme en afrique du sud ou au rwanda il
faut que les victimes et les bourreaux
dialogue que la rédemption ouvre les
voies du pardon charles konan banny
c'est un copain nous étions ensemble en
terminale au lycée d'abidjan il ya bien
longtemps la côte d'ivoire alors été
prospère et pacifique
si loin de ces horreurs que les enfants
savent trop bien mi mai
[Musique]
les cérémonies comme celle là seront
elles un emplâtre sur une jambe de bois
ou parviendront-elles à cicatriser les
blessures encore brûlante dans chaque
camp il a été attaqué par trois
personnes qui avaient des machettes
jusqu'à présent il ne sait pas qui a
fait ça mais aujourd'hui c'est une
nouvelle tout ce que je dois vous dire
c'est de laisser tomber tout ce qui
s'est passé ce délai si tomber le pardon
le pardon le pardon pardonner plutôt que
condamner colombani y croit le nouveau
pouvoir semble le vouloir mais les
clivages ethniques exacerbée par les
chefs politiques depuis 10 ans restent
vivaces la tête de côte d'ivoire a
souffert elle a été forcée de boire le
sang de ses enfants par nos propres
turpitudes
nous ne voulons plus que les ivoiriens
se comporte d'abord comme ben ali comme
péter comme yacouba congrès comme
mannequin comme lobby sympa d'origine
ethnique que nous devons mettre en avant
d'abord c'est la nation ivoirienne que
nous allons préparer ensemble c'est
parce que nous sommes divers que nous
devons être
[Applaudissements]
charles konan banny a deux ans pour
réussir la réconciliation
il mise sur les jeunes et surtout sur
les femmes pour retrouver le temps béni
de l'entente on a l'impression quand
même que le rôle de la femme dans cette
affaire de réconciliation est très
important tout à fait ce que celui de
jeunesse explique de l'homme ouais mais
là la femme bien sûr nous pensons que
nous devons jouer les premiers rôles
pour la réconciliation parce que c'est
nous les femmes qui avaient été les plus
touchés par cette affaire
c'est ni les femmes qui avons perdu nos
maris qui sommes devenues veuves
c'est nous les femmes qui avaient perdu
nos enfants et les femmes qui ont perdu
cinq six enfants qui ne sont plus un âge
de procréer alors nous avons le devoir
nous les femmes de nous les vignes de
merton des sentinelles pour la
réconciliation
mon copain charles a manifestement
réussi sa vie sa vie là où il me reçoit
en témoigne vous avez à accepter plus
comme job en fait une mission au sens
réel du terme un vrai qu'il ya quelques
têtes de christie sea king nous
entourent à tout instant l'édifice peut
se casser la figure
est ce que vous y pensez de temps en
faisant tout offert peut se casser la
figure parce qu'il peut y avoir à
l'attentât sauf là
notre coup d'état l'assassinât et là hop
tout le chemin que vous avez fait je
suis tellement d'accord avec ça et je
suis si quelquefois j'ai je suis inquiet
c'est un pansement cela ça veut dire que
la paix est une épreuve la pète ne
prouve cet honneur de longue haleine
quand on l'a perdu c'est difficile
reconstruit nous sommes dans fins de
reconstruction de la côte d'ivoire pays
de paix nous sommes dans une phase pour
ramener la paix dans le coeur dans les
comportements
mais l'exemple vient de haut évidemment
oui et donc c'est le comportement du
président sa capacité à comprendre qui
feront la différence
oui je pense que de ce côté là et il a
donné la preuve il a choisi de mettre en
place une commission donc c'est un acte
volontariste et c'est pour cela que nous
nous estimons que le choix de modèles
que nous avons fait un petit peu c'est
difficile bah ça le plus le moins
compliqué nous aurons pas à juger et a
condamné à mettre en prison
nous offrons le barreau me disant si
vous voulez pas me reconnaissez vos
erreurs
vous pensez avoir quel pourcentage de
chances de réussite même si c'est un
pouce en défense le la jouer à fond
vous savez vous savez dans les courses
de chevaux en contre sans un poteau ça
quand ça rentre
merci d'écouter onuci fm c'est l'heure
de l'information tout de suite le titre
à la une de ce journal en côte d'ivoire
l'onuci la mission des nations unies a
au moins gagné la bataille des ondes sa
radio est la plus écoutée du pays elle
matraque les tubes et les messages de
paix
oh
milan se tenait là
lui ai fait mon coeur
naturel atteint
meyer
[Musique]
oui
l'inter
[Musique]
de la bonne musique des slogans
percutants cela suffira-t-il à éliminer
la vermine qui insidieusement depuis 20
ans ronge pourri la côte d'ivoire
tout a commencé en décembre 93 le vieux
lesage le père de la patrie au feu de
bois ni meurt une guerre de succession
s'ouvrent ou à taraz son ancien premier
ministre est l'un des favoris
il peut gagner l'élection présidentielle
pour lui barrer la route
ses adversaires mettent au point un
poison qui va détruire le bel équilibre
les séparent au fouet l'ivoirité pour
avoir la nationalité ivoirienne
il faut désormais être descendant de
père et de mère ivoiriens qui doivent
être eux mêmes ivoiriens de naissance
cela permet d'écarter ouattara dont la
mère est burkinabè mais l'ivoirité va
provoquer des clivages ethniques et des
haines dans tout le pays et suivie dit
les supporters du front populaire
ivoirien crient victoire sur des airs de
carnaval en octobre 2000 laurent gbagbo
le vieux rival socialiste de ouattara
est élu
deux ans plus tard le nord du pays à
majorité musulmane se soulève
la côte d'ivoire se retrouve séparé en
deux il faudra huit ans de laborieuses
négociations pour que gbagbo accepte
finalement d'organiser de nouvelles
élections
ouattara peut se présenter à la
présidentielle et ils l'emportent
selon les observateurs internationaux en
2010 gbagbo dénonce des résultats
truqués
il refuse de céder la place une nouvelle
guerre civile la plus sanglante éclate
avec l'aide ponctuelle mais décisive de
l'armée française les forces du nord
finissent par l'emporter en avril
dernier
ouattara peut enfin prêté serment comme
président quant à gbagbo après sept mois
de détention dans le nord du pays
il vient d'être transféré à la cour
pénale internationale de la haye
maintenant je voudrais m'adresser à
monsieur gbagbo
je vous prie monsieur de vous les v
macbu devra répondre d'une partie des
3000 morts de la crise post électorale
comme on l'appelle pudiquement en côte
d'ivoire pour comprendre le chemin qu'il
reste à parcourir vers la réconciliation
il suffit de se rendre dans l'ouest du
pays adou ekoué
dans cette ville de 72 mille habitants
les massacres interethniques ont atteint
des sommets le quartier carrefour a été
le plus touché ici beaucoup de familles
ont été décimées
bernadette a perdu un de ses frères
enterré à la va vite
j'étais moi moi j'étais dans deux ans
avec apparat donc son génie avec les
gros bateaux on est dedans qu'ils ont
passé la porte des vieilles pas d'aller
là bas voir mes petits frères qui sont
sortis sous le mag et l'amour propre et
ils deviennent des clapets grâce avant
d'être tué pas donné vous n'aimez plus
pas le monsieur tirer douékoué est une
ville martyre après l'élection
présidentielle il y a un an ce sont
d'abord les milices de gbagbo qui
massacrent les partisans de ouattara
puis en mars la ville est conquise par
les forces du nord
c'est le début d'une semaine de tueries
ciblées
un véritable nettoyage ethnique
ces tueries de doué coup et aurait fait
environ un millier de morts mais le
bilan précis est toujours inconnue à ce
jour
[Musique]
venez aussi
bernadette a pu s'enfuir un mois plus
tard lorsqu'elle revient au village pour
chercher le corps de son frère un voisin
lui indique ce puits
et puis j'avais gardé bien il ya des en
3d d'un jeu légal je vois quelqu'un qui
a su concentrer là on est venu que mon
petit chou croissant c'est nous qui
soigne le ca les petits qui sont des
lieux saints on nous tue l'effort que sa
recette
on est tous à quoi d'ado pourquoi ado
nous qu'on n'a pas la bonne ou qu'on n'a
pas comment nous tue pourquoi
maintenant bernadette assurent seules la
charge de son neveu des cinq ans
[Musique]
les soldats d fr c é les forces
républicaines de côte d'ivoire du
président ouattara ainsi que leurs
supplétifs devront certainement rendre
des comptes devant la cour pénale
internationale
le tribunal a ouvert une enquête pour
crimes de guerre et crimes contre
l'humanité
une douloureuse épine dans le pied de
ouattara en attendant des militants de
la ligue des droits de l'homme
ivoirienne parcourt la région pour
recueillir les témoignages des victimes
comme thérèse vous ne verrez pas le
visage de cette femme
elles travaillent la peur au ventre ici
les ennemis de la justice les acteurs et
les complices des crimes peuvent frapper
à chaque instant dans ce village 24
habitants ont été assassinés neuf mois
après le massacre les traces n'ont pas
disparu pendant des heures sur son petit
cahier thérèse va tout noté l'identité
des victimes
les circonstances des assassinats
[Musique]
foncier les garçons qui veut tuer les
gars sont enfuis challandes dawa à doyen
petty qui vivait mon nom et au contenu
et les antes appelé maintenant devant
l'outaouais soit elle ou quoi j'ai comme
un mouton en recoupant les témoignages
thérèse à cerner les motivations des
tueurs dans les enquêtes nombreuses
personnes disaient la boulot qui
venaient les amis me disaient de vous
avez voté pour pouvoir voilà pour la
boutique ça c'est le premier slow dans
le désert slogan y en a qui disent bon
on va vous tuer parce que où on va
s'emparer de vos femmes et puis prendre
voté aujourd'hui ses habitants veulent
être reconnus comme victimes
c'est la condition pour la
réconciliation du beaucoup des gens il
faut la justice c'est pas donné mais un
jour il faut que justice soit faite
chez moi tant que justice n'est pas fait
je n'ai pas pas donné
un homme vient chercher thérèse son
frère en agriculteur a reçu une balle
dans le pied lors d'une razzia
il s'est caché pendant un mois dans la
brousse et sa blessure s'est aggravée il
n'a plus qu'un moignon depuis il se
terre ici ils ont dit que c'est un
musicien des barbeaux ses coups de pied
haut n'a pas musardé wabo il n'a jamais
tiré fizi une scène difficilement
supportable pour thérèse cette violence
politico-ethnique la ramène à son
histoire personnelle
elle dit avoir été violée lors de
l'offensive des forces du nord doit
courir restera dans l'histoire
la ville martyre de côte d'ivoire ce que
en tout cas moi j'ai ressenti ici c'est
qu'il persiste et quand même un
sentiment de peur à ces grands peur de
l'autre et l'ua
tout le monde a peur je peux vous
assurer je réponds plus loin les
ivoiriens ont encore peur ils ont le
souvenir de ce qui s'est produit
maintenant deuxième opus si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
en fait un manque de confiance la
confiance les uns dans les autres
ne pas voir venir ont créé l'autre parce
qu'on n'a pas encore suffisamment
confiant tous ses livres et vous avez
raison on ne peut pas dialoguer si on
n'a pas confiance alors comment vous
allez faire
on va faire de la pédagogie pour
éliminer la peur pas seulement de la
pédagogie d'ailleurs par exemple les
problèmes de sécurité qui sont quand
même une raisons pour lesquelles les uns
les autres ont peur aussi vous voulez
d'insécurité cette question là peuvent
être résolus
la peur le retour trop long à une
sécurité pour tous ses biens l'obstacle
principal à la normalisation
huit mois après la fin de la crise le
pays compte encore 170 mille déplacés et
160 mille exilés au ghana et au libéria
le retour chez eux des déplacés sera
l'un des signes majeurs de l'avancée du
pays
dans l'ouest le problème est crucial
mais même à abidjan et sa région
plusieurs camps subsiste encore ici à
bingerville une église évangéliste
abrite 1700 personnes derrière de hauts
murs et dans des conditions d'hygiène
précaires
[Musique]
ici aussi les gens ont tout perdu leurs
maisons pillé brûlé et aussi leur
travail ils sont coincés tétanisés le
gouvernement a beau les inciter à
rentrer chez eux a beau leur répétait
qu'il ne risque plus rien eux n'y
croient pas trop de rumeurs
elles en ont marre comme ça un peu plus
répandues comme l'affût si les vma le
tuer de lui qu'elle s'en faire plus
serait pas envie de retourner chez vous
c'est bien sûr j'ai envie de retourner
pourquoi ne fait pas naturellement non
j'ai besoin d'une sécurité pourront donc
en fait la vérité des choses c'est que
c'est les gens ne retournent pas dans
leur quartier c'est parce qu'ils ont
peur en fait c'est vrai vous avez peur
jour j'étais à cause de votre origine
ethnique
alors où des gens qu'on nous comme ça
qui ont fui la maison après six mois
quand vous allez retourner à la maison
qu'est ce qui vous garantit que non que
vous serez tranquille chez vous les
prêtres de l'église évangéliste qui
héberge ce conte sont eux aussi des
déplacés et ils ressentent aussi ce
sentiment d'insécurité merci beaucoup de
bons jeux - je suis venu mais cas c'est
d'ici que je vois je me suis caché des
armes
je fuis des arbres je fuis les usa et au
bout des armes il ya désormais oui mais
alors vous vous êtes caché
nous y sommes si tu c'était les hommes
alarmes et les hommes en treillis et
ceux qui se posaient les héros savais
pas que d'un côté on s'en fout décider
quel côté il se trouve qu'ils n'avaient
qu'à j'ai peur de rentrer chez moi parce
que là-bas au matin pour dix noms celui
là on l'accuse de temps et temps parce
qu'on sait pas de quoi on nous accuse et
puis bon les gars c'est ce que tu sont
là pour aller chez ils ont peur du parti
donc si lui c'est qu'il arrive à ivana
la mort même si tu lui donnes des
millions il apparaît qu'elle signe il
faudrait pour que vous pensiez vous oui
que c'est réellement tranquille si c'est
quoi le signe qu'il faudrait il ya tout
le monde en a
tout le monde pouvait déposer tous ceux
qui en on pouvait rentrer dans les
casernes
s'ils sont réellement des militaires
s'ils n'ont pas démérité alors qu'on
quitte dépôt des armes et on n'aura pas
peur
le premier des devoirs du président
ouattara c'est bien d'offrir à chaque
ivoirien une certaine quiétude
une vie où l'on ne redoute pas à chaque
instant de se faire agresser
les armes circulent un peu partout dans
le pays et aux conflits ethniques
s'ajoute une délinquance provoquées par
les difficultés économiques
la police et la gendarmerie trop proches
de l'ancien pouvoir ont été désarmés en
attendant qu'elles puissent à nouveau
remplir leur rôle
ce sont les soldats de ouattara les fr
ceni qui se charge du maintien de
l'ordre au bord voici le commandant
wattao l'un des plus fidèles chef de
guerre du président un géant accueillant
mais un brin mégalo il ne se déplace
jamais sans son caméraman personnel
après dix ans d'exil forcé dans le nord
il est revenu à abidjan en vainqueur
avec ses hommes il était aux premières
loges lors de l'arrestation de laurent
gbagbo en avril dernier
ces images où il aide le président déchu
à revêtir une chemise propre ont fait le
tour du monde
aujourd'hui wattao commandes de toute la
zone sud de la ville sans pouvoir et son
influence sont immenses c'est un
seigneur de la guerre n'est pas la
solution
l'afrique est peut-être beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion wattao jouit pour l'instant
d'une énorme popularité dans le secteur
qu'ils contrôlent de jour comme de nuit
lorsqu'ils patrouillent
il est ovationné
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
permanent
sarah beydoun bas qu'ici on n'a même pas
dans la vienne
maintenant on nous aide aussi beaucoup
donné ces informations
wattao rassure c'est un oiseau de bon
augure
wattao et ses hommes dans le quartier
c'est l'assurance de retrouver un peu de
tranquillité de sortir de s'amuser
c'est pas très rassuré un peu la
population
pouladi me semble vraiment suer tous les
éléments aussi malin la jumelle qui
dorment la nuit tu veux la promettre de
bêtises notre client était cassé le bras
wattao ne se prive pas de faire une
petite tournée chez les policiers
ici les flics s'isole dans leur
commissariat ils n'ont plus d'armes pour
se défendre
tous ont servi gbagbo est dans les rangs
des frc des vainqueurs certains ne se
privent pas de les menacer
ouais ya des éléments facile qui ont eu
un malin plaisir devenus les maîtres des
flammes a qui veulent mener ces [ __ ]
comme serrée à tous vous voyez que c'est
un peu difficile
ben c'est bon elle a beau conte service
vous tant que l'armée n'aura pas regagné
ses casernes qu'une nouvelle police
n'entrera pas en fonction les incidents
continueront de nombreux voyous travesti
avec de faux uniformes de l'armée se
livrent à toutes sortes d'intimidations
et de racket
le commandant wattao traque les fr c'est
vrai ou faux qui profite de l'uniforme
cette nuit devant un bar il tombe
justement sur deux jeunes soldats en
vadrouille
y'a des gars légumes
ce désaveu
arte de fouiller les véhicules à mater
la teda voulais te poser à lézat ça va
on doit monter
[Musique]
procès de daube et voilà deux obtenues
elles sont venues d'alain bas et alors
ça sera quoi la sanction mais c'est la
prison la prison militaire
combien de temps oui jours d'arrêt vous
êtes ferme aux ânes on la joue catégorie
il faut la rigueur pour que ça marche
jean rééduquer les troupes constituer
une armée régulière
la tâche est immense et indispensable je
retrouve le commandant à son qg
la caserne de la garde républicaine à
treichville un quartier du sud d'abidjan
comment ça va sur le parking
plusieurs voitures de luxe un butin de
guerre même pas dissimulé mais wattao
c'est que cela ne peut pas durer
il doit mettre de l'ordre la garde
républicaine qu'il dirige est censé être
une troupe d'élite au moins deux robots
au beau frère le message que yahoo donné
ce soir c'est toujours le même message
vous êtes là pour la population vous
demandez sécuriser les aider à poêler
les volets ni julie quand vous sortez
pour la patrie c'est pas pour racketter
nique ou plus mais la population et vous
a toujours répété ça fait attention aux
droits de l'homme
ces baisers on n'a pas fait ce boulot
c'est fini ces armées nationales
régulier qu'elle a donc il faut que tout
le monde se mette au pas j'ai dit tout
ce qu'ils voient des cons et nous on
leur a dit ça c'est clair et net
la récréation et ses baisers version
très local du ce et compris bien reçu et
cher
[Musique]
à 41 ans
wattao prépare déjà sa retraite il
voyage aux etats-unis en europe
s'organise il m'invite chez lui donc ses
ventes amplement voilà voilà un
campement en fait une ville à mes
entrepôts me résidence beaucoup de
chiens ouais wattao possède une douzaine
de chiens de toutes les races sont
favoris un husky un chien de traîneau
importé d'amérique
c'est la plus fidèle wattao sommes bien
ce qui n'enlève rien à la jovialité de
son accueil et la rumeur dit que le
commandant est investi dans de nombreux
business limite limite mais rien
d'illégal ils l'affirment
vous pouvez seulement cela a fait du
n'importe quoi qui va respecter ce
plaisir personne on dirait même voulait
de céder sa chaîne résidents et vous
diront que mécène band voit le banc de
bandits qui sur le plaisir la salle non
de vous montrer une image correcte ils
disent pas qu'il dise pas que vous êtes
des voyous disent que vous aimez bien le
business quand même à compatir parce que
d'abord une somme de nordistes sont
commerçants de nez des comptes commerce
a été là mon père est là aujourd'hui
mais je peux compter sur moi sur mon
salaire de l'armée sur hama
vous savez c'est la grande famille nous
avons besoin quand même de faire des
petits business ni complément l'aide de
compléments mais légal nous ne voyons
pas la drogue voilà qu'on nous annonçait
le truc vraiment légal le business le
business acceptable c'est quoi pour au
moins le binât s'établissent à quoi
acheter une voiture avec un bénéfice
après à là c'est un autre coup venir
devant la vague un bénéfice arrêtable
sacré personnage se wattao son prestige
dans l'armée ont fait un homme clé pour
le nouveau pouvoir et ça lui donne
quelques passes droits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les journaux eux n'ont pas enterré la
hache de guerre
il continue à se battre à coups de
manche est de gros titres vengeurs ou
menaçants c'est la danse du scalp et de
la désinformation
[Musique]
les tabloïds use des recettes de la
presse de caniveau
il existe une douzaine de quotidiens à
abidjan autant de brûlot sur le chemin
de la réconciliation
[Musique]
je suis allé voir un vieil ami venance
konan
il est le nouveau directeur de
fraternité matin si son journal est
financé par l'état
venance reste un des rares journalistes
ivoiriens indépendant il a été menacé de
mort à plusieurs reprises il a dû
s'exiler un temps aujourd'hui il ne se
déplace jamais sans un garde du corps
venance tente avec bravoure d'imposer un
journalisme plurielle et informatique on
a beaucoup reproché aux médias ivoiriens
surtout à la presse écrite plus qu'à la
télévision de m dans toute cette période
énormément d'huile sur le feu toute
affaire et je reconnais que nous avons
joué très mauvais rôle je suis
totalement depuis 90 on a vu moi
journaliste que je veux c'est qu'on
écrivait et démons est scandalisé et ces
journaux sont d'abord des genoux
d'opinion et les gens qui écrivent dans
ses journaux la sauce avant tout des
militants
ils sont des militants avant dé des
journalistes alors vous êtes donc à la
tête de cette fraternité matin et vous
avez besoin de vos dernier édito qui
s'appelait je crois en attendant
l'ivoirien nouveau on fait quoi en
attendant mais en attendant ivoiriens
nous faut que nous qui sommes assez peu
de stabilité nous prêchons par l'exemple
il faut qu'au niveau de gouvernement
mais qu'il n'y a pas de corruption il
faut que au niveau de l'éducation
inculque de nouvelles valeurs aux
ivoiriens il ya quelques années des
étudiants tuer et violer sur les campus
en toute impunité
on avait des étudiants battre des
magistrats des professeurs toute
impunité
il faut que ça cesse il faut qu'on ait
crû que de nouvelles valeurs aussi
variés il faut que les religieux prêche
autre chose que la haine
il faut que les enseignants les parents
chacun joue sa partition pour que l'on
bâtisse et nous voir et nouveaux qui est
respectueux d'un minimum de valeurs dont
la première est le respect de la vie
humaine
bâtir un ivoirien nouveau voilà le grand
défi est ce une utopie
pas sûr mais ce sera long très long et
puis il ya ces milliers d'hommes souvent
jeunes qui ont pris les armes pour
défendre leur leader leur famille leur
quartier ou leur bien enrôler dans des
mouvements de jeunesse des milices ou
des groupes d'autodéfense ils sont
toujours là désoeuvrés mais leurs armes
cachées quelque part à portée de main
comment les désarmer sans provoquer
l'étincelle qui à tout instant peut
encore ravivé le feu
comment les démobilisés quel avenir leur
offrir dans la vie civile la tâche est
compliquée délicate
le gouvernement s'y emploie avec l'aide
de l'onu
il y a régulièrement à abidjan ces
derniers mois des sortes de cérémonie où
les miliciens viennent volontairement
déposé leur artillerie personnel kouassi
sophie da camara gomez la responsable du
désarmement de l'onu si nous sommes dans
le quartier d'attécoubé
la population a été prévenue par des
messages diffusés sur des radios
le périmètre est sécurisé pour éviter
tout accrochage et convaincre ceux qui
hésitent encore à rendre fusils
mitraillettes
les grenades ya jamais de désarmement
sans confiance et sans me sens mieux
4' politique est donc là il ya un
travail qui est beaucoup plus complexe
et entrailles de négociation de
confiance pour que il arrive à nous dire
la vérité parce qu'effectivement dans la
réalité nous savons que les armes sont
toujours là dans la réalité ou savons
qu'ils ne sont pas tout à fait démonter
mais c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
faire brutalement en arrivant en disant
voilà rangs des nouveaux hommes ça ne
marche pas comme ça mais ça marche
autrement 1,1 des hommes arrivent comme
ce commerçant qui avait acheté un fusil
pour défendre sa boutique il ya même un
groupe entier de combattants de
miliciens encore accoutrés de leurs faux
uniformes
on a près pour déposer a terminé 6ème
men à la guerre est finie il faut qu'on
dépend de l'état vous êtes un groupe
important de combattante qui est prêt à
donner lézard noir c'est ça mais vous en
parler on était très content c'est ça ce
matin on est là on est venu voir comment
ça se passe à l'intérieur d'autres
attendent ceux là ont combattu pour
ouattara
les pro gbagbo eux préfèrent rendre
leurs armes discrètement dans l'anonymat
oumar fait partie de ces abidjanais qui
se sont engagés pour libérer leur ville
du clan gbagbo
sa kalach il l'a prise un soldat en
fuite
votre métier c'est quoi oumar a perdu
son emploi comme tous ces hommes jeunes
et souvent chômeurs il espère troqué son
arme contre l'assurance de retrouver une
place dans la nouvelle côte d'ivoire
les gars a dit si ça vous dit toujours
plongés j'ai senti un peu frustré et si
c'est la deuxième hypothèse qui est la
mauvaise si c'est le deuxième cas vous
allez faire quoi si vous êtes un peu
déçu s'il y avait des 617 du si vous
avez senti six mois déjà et en dehors
bon alors au trésor d'accord
j'étais
[Musique]
le message est reçu cinq sur cinq par
l'onuci
attention on n'est pas en train de faire
ça il ne viendrait par un donc chaque
combattant nous leur donnons une carte
de désarmement et à partir de là on va
les suivre les accompagner dans un
processus de réinsertion sociale
un petit paquet du un petit appui à la
réinsertion des formations les apu
retour à la vie civile développement des
choses comme ça l'oeuvre d'argent jamais
de cash
je mets jamais de cash d'abord par son
timbre est fondamental c'est qu'on ne
peut pas racheter là
c'est au tour d'oumar de dire adieu à sa
kalach
il a embrassé profit des gros fail en
m'énervant et qui dit oui
bilan de la journée une trentaine
d'armes à feu collecté des dizaines de
grenades et des kilos de munitions
c'est presque dérisoire mais c'est un
pas de plus vers la normalisation
je fais ce métier est partout j'ai
travaillé depuis la colombie jusqu au
népal c'est vraiment le désarmement
contribuer à la sécurisation
il contribue à la réconciliation parce
qu'il peut retrouver la confiance mais
ça ne suffit jamais donc on soit le
processus de désarmement des combattants
non mais ne vous laissera pas en place
l'association dialogue national que
l'espace politique il faut des élections
livre il faut beaucoup de charisme et
non en fait on met notre petite pierre
dans l'édifice mes médecins c'est déjà
très important
oumar lui semble y croire
trop peut-être bon alors ça y est vous
l'avez la carte la caf et alors ils se
posent avait le sourire ou pas le
sourire
au début le 10ème édition
les black cats c'est ça suffit la
science mais ce contre quoi
la nation vous dit vraiment je vais pas
rester chaud mais à d'accord c'est une
assurance contre le chômage de chômage
avec ce qu'on vous a dit la brindille
si jamais vous en trouviez pas et si
vous nous avez plié ou une blague on est
là et note disant ça ne va pas atteindre
la rive
pourquoi pas si j'ai déposé les armes
ont promis du travail est gay je n'en ai
pas eu un an deux ans quand même c'est
bien convaincante et du centre droit et
non quand ça va dégénérer la masse en
plus aux il a réagi ottomani d'accord
alors maintenant il vous manque enlever
ce qui ressemble à bon entendeur salut
allez bonne chance
70% des ivoiriens ont moins de 30 ans le
président ouattara doit réussir l'autre
grand défi de son mandat la relance de
l'économie et l'emploi des jeunes s'il
ne donne pas rapidement des signes
l'explosion sera cette fois social et
traversera les ethnies en se baladant
dans abidjan aujourd'hui il semble bien
que le gouvernement les compris par tous
la ville est en chantier
les infrastructures se développent les
investisseurs reviennent
l'état met le paquet pour que la côte
d'ivoire retrouve son statut de vitrine
de l'afrique de l'ouest
abidjan se prépare un immense lifting
je rencontre jean louis billon pdg du
premier groupe du pays
il est aussi président de la chambre du
commerce et de l'industrie
direction l'extrême nord du pays
dans la préfecture de niellé une mine
d'or exploitée par les sud africains
doit être officiellement inauguré ce
jour là par le président ouattara
jean louis billon a payé un lourd tribut
à la crise postélectorale lui aussi
menacé de mort par les milices de gbagbo
il a pu s'exiler in extremis son
directeur général d'alors yves lamblin
n'a pas eu cette chance il a été exécuté
aujourd'hui jean louis billon veut
tourner la page
c'est la première inauguration vous
faites président l'a depuis qu'il est en
en situation pour une entreprise je
crois oui oui
d'autant suivre
[Musique]
on espère que l'investissement va
reprendre fortement l'investissement
national d'investissements directs
étrangers
parce qu'on en a besoin et nous on a une
économie qui exemple encore fait la
visite que l'on va faire
le fait que le président république soit
là c'est extrêmement symbolique c'est un
signal pour dire aux investisseurs
étrangers
entre autres venez chez nous oui mais en
même temps
c'est pas seulement un symbole
c
c'est une réalité 2
d'investisseurs qui attendait cette
sortie de crise pour vraiment s'épanouir
s'affirmer sur le tarmac d'une piste
d'aviation à latérite et sous un cagnard
généreux je vais enfin rencontré celui
qui tient entre ses mains le futur de la
côte d'ivoire
[Musique]
alassane dramane ouattara dit ado
le protocole est en place
le président est accueilli comme il se
doit en grande pompe ouattara fils de
commerçants du nord économistes éduqué
aux états unis ancien premier ministre
ancien numéro deux du fmi
marié à une française aura donc attendu
presque vingt ans pour accéder à la
magistrature suprême
ouattara est reçu en héros et en fils du
pays et la population qu'il admire tant
espère qu'il fera des miracles
les graves difficultés économiques qu'a
traversée la côte d'ivoire ces vingt
dernières années explique aussi pour une
bonne part la crise politique qui a
secoué le pays
30% des ivoiriens sont au chômage la
moitié des entreprises ont fermé la côte
d'ivoire dépend presque totalement de
ses exportations de café et surtout de
cacao
elle doit diversifier ses productions
ouattara mise sur l'industrie les
richesses minières et les services pour
relancer son économie
cette mine quel symbole de la terre
jaillit l'or
ouattara l'alchimiste c'est tout bénef
ce président est impressionnant
impressionnant je vois également que les
ivoiriens ça veut dire qu'il ya une
création d'emplois je me suis sûr quand
la reconstruction parmi tous les
problèmes vous devez affronter civile
l'objectif principal est tout à fait
parce que la reconstruction contribue
également à la réconciliation si les
gens d emploi ou sa facilité de
l'arrivée la tolérance réciproque
donc avant tout la conscription économie
la côte d'ivoire a du potentiel comme
disent les experts
la croissance devrait atteindre 8% cette
année
jean louis billon se veut optimiste mais
il lance un appel direct à la classe
politique
la crise doit nous servir de leçon et
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit la
responsabilité pour qu'on sorte
définitivement de cette crise incombe
essentiellement notre classe politique
c'est elle qui attisent les haines
aujourd'hui si nous repartons avec la
paix avec la stib et la stabilité
les projets vont arriver nous mêmes
entrepreneurs locaux
nous allons déployer des projets que
nous avons dans les tiroirs
notre souhait c'est que il y ait
beaucoup de pme qui soient aux mains des
ivoiriens
oui bien sûr il faudrait qu'il y en ait
des milliers voire des millions sans les
pme une grande entreprise peut pas vivre
et nous avons besoin de consommateurs
l'emploi créer l'emploi l'investissement
créer un investissement a votre avis il
faudra un combien de temps pour arriver
à ce que vous deveniez la vitrine de
l'afrique occidentale
si nous connaissons cinq ans de
stabilité je pense nos parties seraient
gagnés il faut que nous gagnons la
réconciliation et les établissements
réelle de la démocratie que cette
culture démocratique soirée le risque
c'est que nous échouons dans notre
processus de réconciliation
l'avenir de la côte d'ivoire est entre
les mains des politiques de tous les
politiques y compris du f pays le parti
de l'ancien président laurent gbagbo
alassane ouattara
je vous là encore une partie difficile
car même s'il a tenu promesse en
organisant des élections législatives le
11 décembre
il n'a pas réussi à obtenir la
participation du f pays
pire en livrant son vieux rival à la
cour pénale internationale
il a provoqué le retrait des pro gbagbo
du processus de réconciliation et donner
raison à ceux qui dénoncent une justice
des vainqueurs
d'après la naa ndiaye politologue
reconnu ouattara doit donner des gages
pour que tous les ivoiriens y compris
les perdants trouvent leur place dans le
jeu démocratique de de votants qui
n'était pas pour le président ouattara
donc été pour gbagbo
ils sont devenus quoi ses 46% je me pose
la question
aussi parce que cette avancée pour cent
sont devenus silencieux ses 46% ont
l'impression aujourd'hui de ne pas
pouvoir s'exprimer et donc ils ont peur
de s'exprimer
ils ont peur d'être
pointé du doigt et de de subir certaines
représailles et ses 46 % c'est quand
même pour moi c'est près de la moitié
d'un terrain de l'électorat et ça me
ferait bien de savoir où ils se trouvent
leur donner la voix est à l'honneur mais
on fait pour y célébrer il appartient au
président ouattara de faire ce qu'il a
promis c'est à dire il a promis le vivre
ensemble
le vivre ensemble commence par là
redonner la confiance à ces ivoiriens
qui ont peur je pense aujourd'hui que il
faudrait donner la voix non seulement à
tous les partisans de l'ancien président
laurent gbagbo aussi donné de la voix à
ceux qui ne sont ni partisans de laurent
gbagbo ni partisans d'alassane ouattara
ils sont tout simplement des citoyens et
qui ont leur mot à dire dans cette
réconciliation
nous avions rencontré peu de temps avant
le transfèrement vers la haye du
président déchu l'un des rares cadres du
parti de gbagbo qui ne soit pas en
prison ni en fuite à l'étranger
il s'appelle justin koua et les
secrétaire général par intérim de la
jeunesse du f pays
déjà il parlait de la difficulté de se
montrer lorsque les partisans de gbagbo
[Musique]
je serai qui ne sera pas le premier
encore pas les ferries
les premières réunions du f pays depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir de ouattara ont été
la cible de provocation mais même s'ils
se disent persécutés
les partisans de gbagbo n'ont pas
capitulé la police ivoirienne et les
casques bleus de l'onu veille maintenant
sur leurs meetings et dans ces
rassemblements
la photo de l'ancien président s'affiche
sans complexe pour ces ivoiriens qui
conteste le résultat des dernières
présidentielles
un seul slogan qu'a lieu de programme
[Applaudissements]
arrivés sur place justin quoi peut enfin
on file est lui aussi un t-shirt à
l'effigié de son héros gbagbo laurent
comme il l'appelle japonais de moins
leader
de l'homme en qui je cours à tout le
peuple et vit au rythme des bandas en
plus en c'est tout le peuple ivoirien
qui est en prison et ce peuple heureux
ni ne demande que sa libération car
selon lui peut sauver la fois deux voies
mais gbagbo laurent est loin de
retrouver la liberté
et même si ouattara a tenté de faire
preuve de bonne volonté en libérant
quelques cadres du fpi
les partisans du président déchu joue
maintenant la rupture
certains candidats pro gbagbo qui
s'était présenté aux législatives en
indépendants se sont retirés et comme
l'annoncé déjà justin quoi il ya
quelques semaines il n'y aura pas de
réconciliation tant que ouattara et son
premier ministre guillaume soro ne
répondront pas à eux aussi de leurs
actes devant la cpi la cour pénale
internationale et audi en réalité si
l'on si l'on maintient pour longtemps
laurent gbagbo dans cet isolement et
qu'ils ont en leur visage son
transfèrement à la cpi en y associant
passe haut de gamme et razvan rat pack
audois de cet euro plus jamais je
pourrais pas se réconcilier paix ne sera
plus jamais retrouvé la preuve on ne se
fera plus jamais khazen des autres un
descriptif heureusement pour les
optimistes
il reste l'autodérision et la bonne
humeur les ivoiriens dans leur malheur
en cette formidable chance de cultiver
en toutes circonstances un joli sens de
l'humour et vos comptes dit tout
tous les dimanches matin à la radio
nationale c'est un festival
bienvenue dans tout couper l'émission
préférée des ivoiriens présenté par
juliette anzian merci bonjour tu vas
bien georges tu vas bien enregistrant ce
matin l'arrivée de nos confrères de
france télévision française est en ce
moment même attendre et sont en train
d'enregistrer l'émission tagué encore
non non les voiles en cause ce programme
satirique met en scène dans un joyeux
foutoir des comédiens et des
journalistes qu incarne chacun à leaders
politiques quoi chefs de tribus ici tout
le monde en prend pour son grade
c'est la règle et quand il parle du
boycott du parti de gbagbo aux
législatives
voilà ce que cela donne un président a
dit je serai tout pour que le pays parce
que si vous désactivez parce que nous
devons être
nous sommes en démocratie et tout le
monde a encore du baril et c'est pour ça
que le président dit que il fera tout
pour que chacun participe pas de la
porte ouverte à tout le monde
on fera tout notre possible que le fn
est ici on a tout fait pour que c'est
que ça aura au ghana nos camions va les
mettre en prison ici
tout ça c'est de retrouver pour donner
la possibilité à tout le monde de
participer au nécessaire à 2 on a tout
fait ce qu'il dit c'est pas qu'est ce
que vous attendez 4 vide et on a rénové
la plus on produit on arrêtait la maca
on appelle des matelas pour mette à la
maca lévénez ça fait quoi votre pays
vous appelle
franchement j'avais des candidats jamais
et là c'est la bonne
pour vous et à la télé mais nous
attaquer ça veut dire finir dans les
temps la scène au seul président au
monde qui n'a pas d'amis aux attentes
aussi j'ai des amis merci j'ai mon ami
kadhafi
ça aussi ça vous fait à temps sa
dynamique et sa miss
barack obama d'un ami bon ce soir ce
sont mes amis la nuit mais la joue le
beau
[Musique]
en fait on a l'impression qu'on s'amuse
mais c'est en fait c'est ça le
l'émission c 'est le toupet moi je suis
parti je suis je suis marocain d'où le
nom reste la côte d'ivoire lui il était
saca il n'ya donc voilà ne sont pas ici
de simples nouvelles est resté des mois
à l'achat mais aussi ce qu'il a dit non
mais sa mère et du centre sans moi je
suis du sud
moi je suis de loin de la beaujoire
ouais je vous fais tout ça qui fait la
côte d'azur il faudrait le micmac ah oui
mais c'est ça la richesse la salle à
manger ils seront d'esclaves
il m'a donné énormément à salut que mon
extrait ce concept optimiste mais oui
très vous êtes obligés d'être optimiste
quant à la capacité d'adaptation de
l'ivoire y est on sait que c'est quelque
chose ya des pays où il ya la guerre et
ils n'ont pas pu rattraper les choses en
deux mois chez nous à peine fini des
activités hors
[Musique]
ce pays je n'ai jamais cessé de
l'observer
il a tant compté dans ma vie j'espère
que la vieille tradition de l'arbre à
palabre autour duquel il suffisait de se
réunir et de parler pour régler les
problèmes les conflits recommencera a
inspiré ce peuple la côte d'ivoire
retrouvera-t-elle sa sagesse légendaire
j'ai envie d'y croire
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon
ah ah